[Musique]
bonsoir très heureux de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle semaine d'information
locale sur tv 78 nous sommes le lundi 11
janvier voici les titres de ce journal
depuis le 1er janvier le royaume uni ne
fait plus partie officiellement de
l'union européenne indique site qui a
des conséquences au niveau local
notamment concernant la mobilité
étudiante que faut-il retenir également
de l'accord conclu entre l'ue et les
britanniques et décryptage avec olivier
janot ex responsable du centre
d'information europe direct à saint
germain en laye en mai dernier la région
ile-de-france débloquer son aide pour
les entreprises lourdement touché par la
crise sanitaire 1,3 milliard d'euros au
total pour ce plan de relance qui
comporte un volet dédié à l'industrie à
ablis et dako france a obtenu une
enveloppe de 700 mille euros pour
augmenter sa production
et puis c'est tout vert depuis le 7
janvier la nouvelle halle du marché des
clayes sous bois accueillait encore des
clients ce dimanche une quarantaine de
commerçants est installé dans le lieu
dont les travaux avaient démarré fin
2018 reportage mais avant de développer
ses titres cette carte de voeux qui fait
polémique car jugés racistes avaient été
envoyés par le commissaire de police de
l'agglomération de plaisir au chef de
service et autorités policières des
yvelines on y voit un policier proche de
sa voiture qui s'adresse à un homme noir
lui disant rapprochez-vous un peu
montazer charge sur l'allume-cigare
cette caricature avait été réalisée en
2015 par wings un dessinateur de presse
qui voulait dénoncer à l'époque les
violences policières aux états unis mais
sahar et utilisation donc en cartes de
voeux a choqué en interne cartes de
voeux qui a fuité sur les réseaux
sociaux
l igpn la police des polices a été
saisie et sur twitter le ministre de
l'intérieur vous le voyez gérald
darmanin a annoncé sa la suspension du
commissaire à titre conservatoire
depuis le 1er janvier le bric site est
donc en vigueur le royaume uni ne fait
plus partie officiellement de l'union
européenne et nombre de choses changent
dans les relations entre les deux
partenaires
on va en parler dans un instant avec mon
invité et c'est le cas notamment dans
ses changements du programme erasmus que
le royaume uni et quitte ce qui impacte
et les conditions d'études pour les
jeunes européens témoignages recueillis
par eléonore sinoquet alexandrine
qu'étudiante en journalisme elle devrait
être en angleterre en ce moment kovy 19
oblige le pays et reconfirme et jusqu'à
début mars et depuis le 1er janvier
le royaume uni ne fait plus partie de
l'union européenne
le break site est entrée en vigueur j'ai
commencé mes études avant décembre 2020
ça veut dire que j'ai juste à
m'appliquer à un truc qui s'appelle lieu
pn salon met ce crime qui me permet de
rester allons bien mes études et de
vivre et de travailler à londres ou dans
l'angleterre a mais les gens qui
commencent rond l'année prochaine en
septembre
ils n'auront pas le droit d'avoir un
prêt étudiant pour les études il on a
besoin d'un visa qui coûte environ 400
euros et aussi lors des prix
international du coup les écoles et
master pour vite fait passer à 30 milles
au lieu de 10 plus tard alexandrine
souhaite travailler au royaume uni une
envie que partage zoé étudiante en droit
et anglais pour elle qui devait partir
en erasmus en septembre ce sera
peut-être plus compliqué moi j'aimerais
beaucoup travailler en diplomatie faire
dieu de la relations internationales et
j'aurais énormément travaillé énormément
aimé travailler en ambassade
après je pense que ce sera toujours
possible enfin j'espère en tout cas mais
je pense que c'est un chouïa plus
compliqué parce que justement on n'a pas
tous ses accords
avec l'union européenne qui permet à
tous les travailleurs de bouger un petit
peu n'importe où en europe
outre l'aspect professionnel et
étudiants le bric site impact aussi
leurs vies personnelles par exemple si
un proche soit de venir les voir en
angleterre
il faudra désormais un visa actuellement
150 mille européens étudient au royaume
uni et on continue de parler de ce break
site avec mon invité olivier jeanne wake
bonsoir bonsoir responsable du centre
d'information europe direct c'est à
saint germain en l'air on va décrypter
avec vous ce bric site qui est entrée en
vigueur on va dire complètement ce 1er
janvier même si le processus avait été
lancé il ya un an l'année 2020 était
finalement une phase de transition est
donc le 24 décembre cet accord accord
historique entre l'union européenne et
le royaume uni pour un accord commercial
et de coopération le moins que l'on
puisse dire c'est que ça a été difficile
à trouver plus de dix mois de
négociations comme on explique qu'ils
aient eu autant de difficultés à trouver
un accord il est effectivement il y
avait beaucoup de difficultés parce que
tout simplement les équipes de
négociation que ce soit de l'union
européenne et du royaume uni ont eu du
mal à se remuer du mal à se mettre
d'accord
bon après c'est le processus assez
classique lorsqu'on négocie un accord
international ou une convention
internationale mais du point de vue
européen il ya eu des cas quelques
reproches qui ont été faits notamment
fait envers l'équipe britannique pour ne
pas avoir exprimé assez rapidement les
souhaits qu'ils les souliers les
souhaits les avancées qui souhaitaient
voir
on imagine aussi un qu' on ne met pas
fin comme ça à 45 ans de vie commune
j'imagine aussi aux attaques c'est un
peu plus compliqué aussi quelle était
l'importance de trouver justement cet
accord est d'éviter ce qu'on appelle le
no deal qui a été qui a longtemps plané
sur sur ces négociations
en fait il n'ya pas vraiment le alors ce
qu'on appelle le nautile en fait c'est
le retour aux règles classiques
bon après ça dépend du domaine qui est
concerné mais par exemple pour le
commerce c'est à dire qu'on revient sur
les règles de l'om s'est donc
concrètement qu'est ce que ça veut dire
c'est que vous pouvez avoir par exemple
certaines productions qui vont être
tarifé sur tarifées et vous pouvez avoir
des surtarification qui peuvent être
assez gênante parfois
à part ça peut monter parfois jusqu'à
plus de 120% de tarification est ce qui
fait que ça peut poser des problèmes
notamment en fait pour des petites
entreprises des pme yvelinoise qui
vivent surtout de l'export et dont le
royaume uni est un est un marché est un
marché important donc justement le fait
d'avoir cet accord est d'avoir réussi à
trouver un accord ça permet d'éviter
justement le no deal ça permet aussi
d'avoir un cadre juridique sécurisé
notamment lorsque par exemple s'il ya
des conflits comment on fait pour régler
ses conflits notamment par exemple en
cas de en cas de signes d'entreprises
britanniques n'a pas payé une entreprise
yvelinoise comment on fait pour
recouvrer les créances et ainsi de suite
dans le cadre de cet accord ça va être
beaucoup plus facilité que si on si on
se contentait des règles omc classique
et donc 1246 page dans cet accord pour
établir les relations commerciales entre
les deux partenaires
il ya notamment on l'a vu la fin de
l'adhésion au programme erasmus par lé
royaume uni on en a parlé dans le
précédent reportage
en revanche l'accord permet de maintenir
un libre échange entre les deux parties
mais avec un alourdissement des
démarches en clair des relations
commerciales qui reste possible mais ça
va être plus encadrés
c'est ça alors jusque là du moins
jusqu'au jeux jusqu'au 1er janvier on
avait ce qu'on appelait donc la libre
circulation des biens la libre
circulation des marchandises et ainsi de
suite ce qui faisait que tout les toutes
les marchandises européennes ou
britanniques pouvaient circuler très
facilement dans l'autre pays et les
entreprises n'avaient pas forcément
beaucoup de démarches administratives à
faire parfois qu'elle est parfois
quasiment aucune démarche administrative
notamment quand on avait une
reconnaissance qu'on avait une
reconnaissance au niveau des produits ce
qui s'est passé c'est que maintenant
cette libre circulation est finie alors
on a mis en place donc on a en fait
supprimer les ce qu'on appelle les
barrières tarifaires c'est à dire qu' il
n'y a pas de limitation au niveau des
quotas on peut exporter les entreprises
européennes peuvent exporter autant
qu'elles le souhaitent au niveau du
royaume uni et vice versa il n'y a pas
deux il n'y a pas de frais de douane
supplémentaires
du moins y'a pas de y'a pas de frais de
douane qui vont s'appliquer
donc pas de surtarification par contre
si on a donc six sur les barrières
tarifaires ça a été supprimé le royaume
uni maintenant à la possibilité
d'imposer maintenant des barrières non
tarifaires c'est à dire que par exemple
elle peut exiger que certains produits
respectent des normes spécifiques par
exemple des normes iso ifo des normes
iso x intel ils peuvent demander à ce
que ces produits les respecte on a aussi
une évolution dans le sens que
maintenant les entreprises britanniques
et les entreprises européennes qui
souhaitent exporter dans le pays
du moins dans l'autre zone maintenant
vont devoir entreprendre des démarches
auprès des douanes
alors il ya différentes démarches
surtout notamment pour les produits qui
sont content on considère que l'origine
et soient européennes soient
britanniques les entreprises en fait ont
la possibilité de se faciliter les deux
se faciliter les démarches en
s'inscrivant auprès d'une base de
données au niveau des douanes ou en fait
ils vont détailler l'ensemble des
processus et origines des différentes
pièces composant composant les produits
autre élément qui est très important
dont j'avais mentionné donc jeu que
j'avais mentionné auparavant c'était le
s'était notamment sur le règlement des
différends une entreprise donc
yvelinoise qui n'est par exemple ne sera
pas payée par une entreprise britannique
ou vice versa il y aura donc possibilité
de régler le différend de manière un peu
plus de manière un peu plus facile que
ce qu'on pouvait que ce qu'on pouvait
connaître
dans le cadre de l' omc et enfin si
effectivement on a supprimé ses quotas
et ses quotas et c'était sur terre c'est
sûr tarification nous avons quand même
la possibilité si on se rend compte que
par exemple un marché est saturé par un
produit venant de tels pays de l'union
européenne ou du royaume uni il ya la
possibilité de mettre en place en fait
des barrières tarifaires afin de limiter
si nécessaire le afin de limiter si
nécessaire le l'afflux de produits donc
venant d'une des deux zones afin
d'éviter une concurrence déloyale
on va terminer cet entretien on arrive
déjà bientôt à la fin de cet entretien
juste en disant que pour plus
d'informations aussi sur ce break site
le centre europe direct je le rappelle
qui rattache à la maison de l'europe des
yvelines vous pouvez le joindre
peut-être au lien qui va s'afficher en
bas de l'écran voilà le lien de la
maison de l'europe notamment des
yvelines qui s'affiche puisque on sait
qu'avec ce brick city aussi la libre
circulation qui est donc terminée vous
pouvez donc joindre le centre europe
direct aux liens que s'affiche en bas de
l'écran sortons de cette thématique du
brics il juste pour une dernière
question avec la journée franco
allemande qui a lieu le 22 janvier
prochain elle met en avant l'amitié
entre les deux pays à cette occasion la
maison de l'europe des yvelines s'est
associé à radio sensations dans un mois
spécial est dédié à cette amitié on va
le voir dans un instant déjà elle sert à
quoi cette journée qu'est-ce qu'elle
célèbre finalement cette journée franco
allemande
cette journée franco-allemande lcl
célèbre surtout la signature donc de ce
qu'on appelle du traité de l'élysée donc
signé le 22 janvier 1963 qui vise en
fait à sceller la réconciliation
franco-allemande donc notamment suite à
la suite à la suite aux différentes
dévastation qui ont été commises pendant
la seconde guerre mondiale le président
de gaulle et le chancelier
et le chancelier adenauer si je me
souviens bien c'était me ont décidé en
fait de mettre fin à ce cycle
destructeur et donc de signer ce traité
ce traité prévoit un dif prévoit tout un
tas d'éléments et dans ces éléments il
ya notamment donc en fait la mise en
place de la journée franco allemande et
la journée franco allemande ou semaine
franco-allemande ça dépend de comment ça
dépend de comment ça s'organise c'est la
mise en place en fait d'activités
permettant de découvrir la culture la
langue de l'autre pays généralement sur
fin janvier et donc sensations je le
disais s'associe à cet événement pour
proposer de mieux comprendre l'amitié
franco allemande moteur de la
construction européenne je précise que
c'est en partenariat avec le fonds
citoyen franco allemand juste avant
d'écouter l'interview express merci
olivier jeannots d'avoir été avec nous
et je rappelle que vous êtes le
responsable du centre europe direct de
saint germain en laye et donc toutes les
précisions sur ce mois spécial dédié à
l'amitié franco allemande sur sensation
dans cette interview express
[Musique]
depuis plusieurs années on consacre
régulièrement des émissions à l'europe
on s'intéresse chaque mois à ce que font
nos voisins européens en matière de
culture d'emploi de santé de droit on a
voulu profiter profité de la journée
franco allemande du 22 janvier prochain
pour proposer à nos auditeurs une
programmation spéciale autour de
l'amitié franco allemande
alors on a reçu pour cela le soutien du
fonds citoyen franco allemand et on a
décidé de mettre en valeur l'importance
des cultures locales au sein de l'europe
avec une meilleure connaissance de la
culture allemande dans tous ses aspects
alors des plus institutionnelle au plus
artistique alors l'essence à reporter
ses des auditeurs l'idée c'est de
demander à nos auditeurs de nous envoyer
des vidéos où il nous explique ce que
représente pour eux l'amitié franco
allemande alors on a reçu des
témoignages très variés de personnes de
tout âge de tout horizon certains nous
ont parlé d' échanges scolaires qui
l'ont fait d'autres de jumelage entre
leur ville est une ville en allemagne
mais certains nous ont parlé aussi de la
fête parce que l'allemagne c'est aussi
synonyme de fête de soirée d'expériences
culturelles comme par exemple
l'oktoberfest que vous connaissez
sûrement et on a sélectionné plusieurs
personnes qui vont venir participer à
nos émissions spéciales et participer à
des rencontres des séminaires organisés
par la maison de l'europe de l'heure et
la maison de l'europe des yvelines
alors le programme va être assez dense
car les relations entre la france et
l'allemagne ont des formes variées c'est
ce qu'on va essayer de vous montrer
pendant toute cette semaine alors dès le
18 janvier
vous aurez l'occasion d'écouter des
entretiens avec des députés des
eurodéputés des historiens des étudiants
et même des restaurateurs qu'on a été
interviewé un peu partout en france qui
vous apporteront un éclairage sur les
relations entre la france et l'allemagne
le 27 janvier on sera en direct du
cabaret du bout des prêts à cerner la
ville avec le soutien du fonds citoyen
franco allemand on va vous proposer une
soirée spéciale qui aurait dû se faire
en public mais ce qui sera
malheureusement que alors l'antenne de
la radio et sur les réseaux sociaux on
proposera à nos auditeurs et internautes
un tour d'horizon de la culture
allemande et française on verra comment
elles se sont influencés avec de la
chanson de l'effeuillage burlesque de la
peinture mais aussi on parlera cinéma et
musique avec fabrice leclerc notamment
journalistes au pao paris match si je
dis pas de bêtises et enfin le samedi 30
et 31 janvier avec nos sens un reporter
dont on parlait il ya un instant ce sera
un week-end spécial franco allemand avec
chaque heure un entretien pour apprendre
à mieux se connaître
et puis on fera une sélection des
meilleurs punchline témoignages que vous
avez pu découvrir au cours de cette
semaine pour en faire un petit recueil
papier papier pardon pour approfondir
les liens franco-allemands
les derniers chiffres de l'épidémie de
covile 19 dans les yvelines sur une
semaine le nombre de contamination
augmente taux d'incidence à 146 le
nombre de personnes contaminées pour
5000 habitants taux de tests positifs en
hausse également au niveau des données
hospitalières le nombre de patients
diminuent dans les yvelines mais plus de
personnes ont été placées en réanimation
+4 en une semaine et depuis le début de
la crise sanitaire le commis 19 a causé
mille cent vingt décès dans les hôpitaux
des yvelines une crise sanitaire qui a
fragilisé l'économie également pour
venir en aide aux entreprises la région
ile de france avait lancé en mai dernier
un plan de relance 1,3 milliard d'euros
au total dans un volet avec un volet
notamment kg et est dédié à l'industrie
c'est à ce titre que l'entreprise daco
france installé à ablis a obtenu une
enveloppe de 700 mille euros pour
augmenter
sa production le reportage de mélanie
poké de pierre hugot reiber chaque année
40 millions de sachets de fruits secs
sorte de l' usine de l'entreprise daco
france une réussite économique mais
surtout familiale qui a commencé il ya
47 ans l'histoire de dako france est une
entreprise familiale qui a été créée par
mon père joseph abitbol et qui en 1974
décide de se lancer sur le marché des
fruits secs et qui est un marché
naissant à l'époque et qui n'a cessé de
grandir
fort de la recherche d'une alimentation
saine pour le consommateur grâce au plan
de relance économique de la région dako
france veut relocaliser la production de
1500 à 2000 tonnes de fruits secs pour
ce projet ils ont bénéficié de sept cent
mille euros de budget on a souhaité
faire appel à ce sont justement pour
continuer notre expansion moderniser
mais surtout réinternaliser des
fabrications qui étaient réalisés à
l'étranger et donc
amener davantage de fabrication sur le
site d'ile-de-france pour relocaliser
créer des emplois des emplois à forte
valeur ajoutée
au total ces douze nouveaux postes à
temps plein qui seront créés grâce à
cette aide l'entreprise yvelinoise fait
partie des 75 lauréate du concours de la
région
on a eu plus de 300 candidatures des
très beaux projets des projets qu'on a
réorienté vers des dispositifs plus
classique de la région et donc on a
durant sélectionnés 75
on a déjà doublé le budget pour ce
dispositif on avait prévu 20 millions
d'euros ce n'est pas ça 42 millions
d'euros
et donc je pense qu'on va peut-être
relancé en ce début d'année pour aider
d'autres belle industrie sans notre
territoire
reste maintenant à savoir si cela
suffira à couvrir les pertes liées à la
crise sanitaire
selon l'insee l'île de france a perdu
26% de son activité industrielle en 2020
en bref le procès pour harcèlement
sexuel avec usage de son pouvoir de
stéphane mirambeau et renvoyée au 16
septembre
l'ancien maire de villepreux de 2008 à
2020 est visé par deux plaintes déposées
par deux femmes en 2019
l effet remonte à 2018 et 2019 stéphane
mirambeau est accusé d'avoir envoyé
plusieurs centaines de messages à
connotation sexuelle des insultes et des
photos pornographiques à l'ancien édile
aurait dû s'expliquer aujourd'hui et
lundi devant la justice l'audience est
finalement reportée pour disposer aide
un créneau plus long pour entendre les
pelles et plaignante et le réquisitoire
après plus de deux ans de travaux c'est
la nouvelle halle aussi du marché des
clayes sous bois qui a été inaugurée il
ya peu ces commerçants et ses clients
pour la première fois longtemps investi
dès la semaine dernière un lieu très
attendue par les habitants et aussi par
les commerçants regardez ce reportage de
mélanie poké de patrick jacques de
dixmude
[Musique]
des achats en musique pour le deuxième
jour d'ouverture les clients de la
nouvelle halle du marché des
clayes-sous-bois répondre présent
impeccable on voit partout cdu c'est
formidable à l'envi l'été vieillot un
voile avait besoin soit pas c'est bien
c'est sympa c'est neuf il ya juste un
truc c'est pour faire la job ça déborde
pour nous ça changeait pas grand chose
mais je pense que pour les commerçants
c'est mieux c'est sympa il a mis très
longtemps à sortir de terre mais il est
bien ça vaut le coup l'ouverture en
janvier a été choisi par les commerçants
pour eux il faut surtout prendre ses
marques et retrouver sa clientèle je
trouve que ça s'est bien passé un peu
trop tard pour les travaux mais très
bien à bien parce qu'on est bien et puis
ne plus plus espacés ce dark très bien
après c'est une question d'organisation
pour s'organiser par rapport à la vente
par rapport à l'étalagé sublet créer un
peu différent mais on s'y fait bien nous
sommes très satisfaits de ce marché il
est bon et tous doivent déjà très
content de retrouver nos clients ce
matin de bonne heure et de bonne humeur
un nouvel établissement qui s'est fait
attendre deux ans de travaux du retard
et un budget de plus de 4 millions
d'euros
on lui souhaite longue vie d'ancien
marché a vécu 45 ans on lui souhaite le
même succès nous sommes globalement
satisfaits ceci dit il ya quand même un
certain nombre de points à revoir que
nous reverrons avec avec
architecte ce qui n'est pas satisfaisant
c'est un certain nombre de retards qui
ont été occasionnés avec certes un
manque de préparation au niveau au
niveau du chantier
l'ancienne halle devrait être détruite
selon du premier semestre de l'année
2000 21 des logements et une place
convivial devrait voir le jour mais du
sport pour refermer ce journal grégory
baugé et prend sa retraite le pistard
yvelinois l'annoncé hier chez nos
confrères de stade 2 il tire sa
révérence à bientôt 36 ans avec neuf
titres de champion du monde de cyclisme
sur piste également vice-champion
olympique de la vitesse individuelle aux
jo de londres en 2012 quatre médailles
olympiques au total il est le coureur
tricolore le plus titré de sa génération
cette information est bien d'autres
encore qui seront à développer dans un
instant l'émission le 7-8 sport revient
pour un premier numéro de cette année
2021 s est présenté bien sûr par michael
et demi d'euros voilà c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de votre fidélité très
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]